[Music]
hello there 2023 is here to kick your
doors down and force you to get a year
older but don't worry 2023 is also one
of the biggest years in video game
history January was once known as the
slowest month of the year but how things
have changed January is packed with AAA
Juggernauts and smaller free experiences
and everything in between so let's do
this
spoken finally arrives in January after
being moved away from the God of War
release in November we play as Faye a
smart talking New Yorker who is
transported into a fantasy world filled
with magic and the occasional Dragon the
action RPG is focused around fluidity in
the traversal as its rapid with free
running elements to satisfy which will
be needed in this open world of athia
combat incorporates that speed with
conjuring spells with over 100 spells in
fact previewers have noticed the game
opens up after the third chapter to
truly Embrace multiple spells switching
mid-battle to tactically out think your
enemy there are four Elemental Magic
types to unlock via skill trees and
speaking of trees the Earth element
allows Fey to conjure roots from the
ground to assist in battle if you're on
the fence like me about this game you
should know there is a demo on the
PlayStation store right now try before
you buy the full release of forespoken
hits PS5 and PC on January 24th
[Music]
an iconic game is getting a long-awaited
reboot this month dead space back when
survival games were constantly trying to
outdo one another with gruesome scenes
and jump scares Dead Space found the
perfect formula trapped in an infested
spaceship the ishimura we play as Isaac
who must restore the ship's power to
escape we quickly realize the crew have
been wiped out by a necro moth Invasion
armed with a trusty plasma cutter and
other weapons we dismember that alien
threat to slow them down Isaac must
survive one of the coolest things added
to the reboot is the existence of random
events over 100 events can happen in any
room of the ship and it's all designed
to keep you on edge the lighting can
malfunction a pipe can burst as you walk
past a vent can slide open which may or
may not have a Necromorph inside Dead
Space plans to keep you terrified from
start to end so if that hasn't scared
you away look out for Dead space's
return on January 27th on PS5 Xbox
series and PC
one piece has received a true RPG video
game in the shape of One Piece Odyssey
alongside extensive exploration the
pirate crew will face off regularly with
foes in a turn-based battle yet these
have been tweaked slightly as a fight
begins each of our crewmates will have
separate zones to fight within instead
of fighting as a collected group this is
designed to reflect the show and allow
each character to use their moves they
are renowned for without overshadowing
their teammates this means unlike other
RPGs you'll be using all characters
equally and not finding the strongest
one and maining them for the entire
story another cool thing is Battle
tweaks which spice up the story a boss
encounter May challenge you to allow
Luffy to hit the final blow to cement
his place as the captain of the team a
little bit of drama for the straw hat
crew one piece Odyssey hits Playstation
Xbox and PC on January 13th
[Music]
okay let's do some free stuff for the
month of January 2023. it's finally time
for cart Rider drift to release a
totally free to play cart racer which is
trying to be serious competition to
Mario Kart but unlike Mario Kart cart
Ryder is completely free to play and
isn't stuck on a Nintendo console it's
got a great chance to Prevail a great
way cart Ryder establishes itself as
something new is via license challenges
this could be a standard race but it
also could be a mini game such as a
water fight with another driver or troll
challenge is to stop a certain player
winning a race and boss fights are here
too chasing down a foe who is constantly
harassing the player with bombs and
other distractions as a free-to-play
game cart Rider has decided the battle
pass is how it'll make money a free and
premium version this means the game is
absolutely packed with unlockables
outfits emotes color schemes as
customization is everywhere cat Rider
drift's release date isn't set in stone
but we do know January is the planned
month of release and January 12th is the
planned week of release on PC Android
iOS Playstation Xbox and switch and
it'll probably run on a Samsung Smart
fridge
[Music]
have you ever played a game like Journey
or flower or flow art games that beg to
be explored right now the next game from
that game company is available for free
we are a child of light donned with a
cape to fly the basic premise is to
understand the World by collecting
Spirits which then unlock new areas
which offer a new challenge like there's
a world filled with rain so we must
focus on finding shelter as rain dampens
our abilities other players can be found
in the game yet we can not talk to them
interacting with them is deliberately
basic but we can request help with a
puzzle we can also give them nicknames
should you see them again at any point
in the game you'll recognize them
immediately Skye children of light first
released as a mobile game before moving
to the switch last year and now it's on
PS4 right now for free for anime fans
keep an eye on January 13th as that is
the release date of the free next-gen
version of Dragon Ball Z Kakarot
dragging that two-year-old RPG up to
Modern standards and just like The
Witcher update last month it does look
good
there is another free-to-play game I
want to put on your radar warlander a
medieval themed free-to-play Warfare
game coming to PS5 Xbox series and PC
the game will support up to 100 players
as they take part in huge battles as
opposing forces on either two or five
armies the gameplay modes we've seen so
far include Castle Siege and a good old
Skirmish our plan is to break into the
opponent's stronghold and destroy their
core various roles have been confirmed
from Warrior cleric and Mage each one
with their own unique abilities the PC
version is here it's ready it releases
on January 24th but the console version
has been delayed and will arrive in
April I'll be sure to tell you about it
again nearer the time but if you have a
PC you can do it this month I really
like the look of warlander
okay back to priced games in fact
reduced priced games a brand new
SpongeBob game is here SpongeBob
SquarePants The Cosmic shake after the
success of the Battle for Bikini Bottom
remaster a few years ago a new new story
was commissioned the mechanics remain
mainly unchanged as the action
platformer we know but notably there are
new skills to master like the fishhook
swing for traversal and the karate kick
for combat SpongeBob SquarePants The
Cosmic Shake hits PS4 switch PC and Xbox
One on January 31st Monster Hunter rise
a former switch exclusive finally comes
to PlayStation and Xbox on January 20th
I'm sure you know about monster hunter
games but if not they're exactly what
they say on the tin traversing into a
small open world like region and
locating a beast to be hunted it's then
a systematic and long-winded battle to
either capture or kill them we then
create new armor sets and new Weaponry
from their bones and scales and then we
go back in and do it all over again rise
introduces a new animal companion as
well as rideable beasts to get around
the world a little quicker which makes
you look like a total badass Monster
Hunter rise also has new DLC coming very
soon so there we have it January the
slow month of the year is pretty good
this time around any thing you're
playing I'm gonna try cart Rider drift
and probably Dead Space idle Diapers at
the ready I'm Adam you're awesome all
the best for 2023 I'll see you next time
[Music]